that whenever you grant perspective you
grant power we've buried our heads so
deeply you know we're sort of all we're
all playing our own little mini games we
like to organize the world into these
simplified little systems of elements
and simple rules and we sort of organize
these mini-games of life and then you
know we try to win them
[Music]
today's episode is about Free Will is
there even a theory of everything and
the physics of idealism that is the
notion that Consciousness is fundamental
and only we also touch on
interpretations of quantum mechanics
where the Observer has a privileged role
in creating the universe Matt O'Dowd is
a science communicator and an
astrophysicist a professor at the City
University of New York involved in
gravitationally lensed quasars which
touch on the crisis in cosmology which
is something that we'll speak about in
this episode and for sure in the next
one at length Matt is also the host of
PBS space-time which has over 2 million
subscribers I think it's 2.8 and they're
the largest physics and space show on
YouTube and in case you're wondering who
I am my name is Kurt J mungle I have a
background in mathematical physics and
this channel is theories of everything
which is dedicated to the theoretical
physics Endeavor of understanding
gravity and Quantum field Theory but as
well as we investigate Consciousness and
the fundamental role it may have if
you're watching this you'll see that I'm
in a new location and all of this I
can't wait to tell you more about in A
Day in the Life episode we're filming a
day in the life and you can expect to
see that in the next couple of weeks you
can also expect many changes behind here
many different angles we're still
setting it up you can also expect three
sponsors in today's episode that is
rocket money Henson and expressvpn again
that'll be around the 20 minute Mark and
then another one at the 40 minute Mark
just telling you here as I like to know
what the sponsors are before I watch a
video and also when they are for full
transparency and also to set
expectations if you're interested in
hearing more podcasts like this then do
consider going to patreon.com
or you can go to
theoriesofeverything.org and supporting
with the contribution of whatever you
like as the only reason that I'm able to
do this full time is because of the
patrons so the supporters like yourself
as well as the sponsors thank you so
much and enjoy this episode with Matt
O'Dowd
Matt
Matt
I've been watching you for years so this
is
that I'm this is a treat this is an
honor man it's good to speak with you
well it's my pleasure I've been watching
you for months right right
and really enjoyed the stuff dude thank
you thank you okay so I want to talk
about PBS space time which is what I
know you from but that's not all you do
it's not your full-time job
so
firstly let's get people who are
unacquainted with you acquainted so what
is PBS space time and how did you get
involved
okay so PBS space time it's a YouTube
show
um uh a PBS YouTube show PBS digital
Studios uh we do near weekly episodes a
few times a month
um and we explore
a huge range of Topics by now because
we've been doing it for seven years uh
and we've gone pretty deep in
you know topics of space and time uh and
you know so physics astronomy
astrophysics uh but this encompasses
encompasses a huge amount of stuff of
course
um is it physics is enormous but we tend
to explore topics in
you know cosmology and quantum mechanics
and you know as as mind bendy as we can
with
the Proviso that we are strictly
scientifically rigorous right which
makes it much different than
the content that at least used to be out
on YouTube and television which was much
more watered down and mystifying playing
up the aspect of the wave and the
particle and pretty much just staying at
that and saying there could be extra
Dimensions without showing many if any
equations
yeah I mean and we actually don't show
Too Many equations but we do show some I
think our
philosophy is more that
um you know people have been consuming
science media for many decades now you
know uh since
since before Carl Sagan's Cosmos and
um it's like people have been in school
for five decades and we decided that
some wanted to graduate
um to stretch an analogy but we you know
we have the philosophy that our audience
is smart people are smart and and you
know the only difference is that they
didn't make poor decisions about staying
in University for way too long and so
that the same level of specialized
knowledge but they do have
good brains uh and and perhaps more to
the point they have fantastic
[ __ ] detectors and so they're very
highly tuned to when you know when
they're being talked down to right so
that's what we wanted to do we wanted to
um bring maybe a peek behind the curtain
of how you know the the particular
sciences that we love the most actually
happen and what some of the very poppy
results that you see in in the media
actually mean and uh yeah we talked
before this and we realize we have
several commonalities so one is we both
research physics the next is we distill
that physics or that research down to
something that's consumable while
correctly portraying the phenomenon so
that is not being patronizing about it
and then number three is filmmaking so
why don't you tell the audience and
myself about this film and why it's
important to you
sure okay so
um
so I you know I
to in answering this question to also
partially answer your last question
which I missed um
I didn't start out planning to make film
when I was a kid I wondered a lot of
weird stuff where did the world come
from what happened before the Universe I
still have the same questions I had as a
kid this documentary will lay out our
best modern understanding of what the
universe really is I
um you know I started out as an
astrophysics researcher I'm a professor
at City University of New York
um you know I teach physics I
do physics I have a research program in
astrophysics but
um
around seven years ago I
um
well I have a friend so my friend uh
Gabe Perez is a New York cosmologist at
the time
was doing this little show with PBS
called space time
um he did several really out of this
world episodes but
had decided to move on and so there was
a bit of a scramble in the New York
astrophysics Community because we'd all
grown up on Carl Sagan uh and you know
we all had this little desire to
um you know not feel the issues but we
saw the importance of the mission you
know there's no point learning how big
the universe is if you don't tell anyone
about it and so so it tends to be you
know a a pattern among particularly
among people in Astro that we like to
talk about this stuff so
so I jumped in
um and for whatever ridiculous reasons I
ended up
um stepping into Gabe's shoes and that
was seven years and what do you mean
that there's no point in learning about
it if you don't talk about it oh so I
guess I mean that uh
uh you know a bunch of
Ivory Tower academics knowing how
amazing the universe is and you know
talking to each other about it but never
never you know sort of let's say
leveling up humanities
Collective reality in that way it's it
is it is a more beautiful thing it's
objectively more beautiful if more
people
um have a more expansive understanding
of of the crazy universe that they live
in um you know particularly in
astrophysics we're not we don't produce
a lot of Industry value you know we
don't make a lot of the new useful Nano
materials for example and so the the
primary use of
the field is perspective
okay so the story of my life so I was no
right uh so so we we really dug into
um to space-time and it was
successful beyond what we imagined could
be could be possible and you know really
what had happened is that we'd you know
maybe let's say we can credit ourselves
with a little intuition here but I think
there was also some luck that we tapped
into a very hungry market for
um for much more authentic science
journalism
um and so you know we
um I mean you know you you need to go
and look at our uh
our video library on YouTube and there's
a lot yeah there will be an overlay
right now for the audience and I highly
recommend you subscribe to PBS space
time uh but it also
you know over that time
um took the little little spark of
passion that I had for science
communication which had previously been
expressed you know doing public talks
and you know doing observing nights uh
for the public and things like that and
I realized that wow there's really
something big that can be done
um
and so
um
so this film uh it's actually
not a PBS production it's a production
with my PBS team as well as my partner
bahara golipur who is a science
journalist uh specializing in
neuroscience and AI
and um so this is what this is this is
our Collective Mission but in a way it's
the culmination of our
our efforts
and
um
so
I mean I can tell you a little bit about
the film
um yeah I would love to hear so uh so
the idea I mean the film is called
inventing reality and the idea is
you know it as I said it's a synthesis
um not just of what we've learned but um
it's an attempt to sort of
put it together step back take stock and
look for pass forward so so maybe a
simple way to say it is that it's a
movie about Humanity's search for what
is fundamental
um and of course there are many ways
that we seek truth but the focus of this
film is the pursuit of the most
fundamental levels of reality through
particularly physics but also science in
general
um
and okay so you know it's about the
question what is reality but it's also
about the meta questions
um so digging into the potential answers
to the question itself but also to
question that question
so
um
physics is
insanely successful almost unbelievably
successful in its predictive power about
nature but uh there's there's a sense
and I think a growing sense that physics
has stalled in I think what some once
thought was this final Sprint to a
theory of everything you know to to
neatly tie up reality in a bow have this
final equation that described everything
uh and so uh so now many physicists are
asking how do we approach the question
differently and not just physicists a
lot of the thinking is Reaching Across
into other disciplines drawing on other
disciplines okay can you give an example
of that because you said you would like
to investigate fundamental reality from
not just a physics perspective but a
science perspective in general what
would that look like if not physics
great question so so I guess um
there's a lot many ways to uh answer
that but
let's just use one so uh
quantum mechanics is
weird beyond comprehension in a very
literal sense we still don't get it
um but it's clear that there is a
an uncanny and fundamental Link Between
The Observer and the nature of the
observed the so-called measurement
problem
and this is a
an unresolved uh
um conundrum that was sort of swept
under the rug you know back in the 1920s
uh when we realized that there was
some kind of
in between
observations there there is there's a
level of indeterminacy to Nature in
which nature
appears to occupy multiple States at
once or no State and it's only defined
on observation and all of this all this
beautiful weird stuff and
um there there was a lot of debate about
you know basically swing between a type
of idealism and a type of realism
um questioning the reality of reality
um and how fundamental The Observer is
but this was pushed aside uh because
quantum mechanics was
incredibly successful at predicting the
behavior of the universe and so you know
the old added shut up and calculate uh
really drove the the philosophy of how
quantum mechanics evolved um
in that we just used it we we used it to
make amazing predictions I think it's
reasonable to say we used quantum
mechanics to build our modern world you
know transition calculate mindset is
what it is yeah yeah it is so it so
for quite some time it was
considered career suicide for an
academic to ask questions like but what
does quantum mechanics actually mean
um what is happening between
measurements for example sort of the the
what we call the interpretation of
quantum mechanics so the equations work
you know the Schrodinger equation or the
equations of quantum field Theory they
work incredibly well but asking the
question what do these equations mean
what is the
physical story that they
are the world
I'm not sure if you've seen the
interview on toll with Tim Maudlin I
have not seen that one yet okay well he
would say so he's a philosopher of
physics and he would say quantum theory
they don't teach you quantum theory they
teach you a method of calculating and a
true theory should give you an account
of ontology so a true theory is a
combination of math and metaphysics or
at least like a supposed account of the
metaphysics and he said that's what most
interested him in physics and they would
talk about that on the first lecture
just to get you involved and then after
that it's calculating greens functions
yeah and he said I'm not terribly
interested in that I want to know what
is going on yeah and he said now if you
ask a physics Professor what is going on
they say go to the philosophy Department
that's not for here yeah they said
that's not how it's been historically
for all of physics even though physics
wasn't coined until fairly recently but
for since even Newton wanted to know
what the heck is going on and Houston
acknowledged that he didn't know what
his so-called theory of gravity meant it
it it he acknowledged that it was not
pontological in any way it was
descriptive and in the in the same way
as
um you know is Newton's law of universal
gravitation is descriptive of gravity it
doesn't explain why gravity happens
quantum mechanics is descriptive of the
behavior of subatomic particles but
doesn't explain the why internet privacy
is a growing concern as we mostly live
our lives online however there are many
ways that we can be attacked or
monitored I personally don't go online
doing what's sensitive without
attempting to use a VPN the reason being
that many internet service providers can
view what you're viewing or view the
websites that you visit and in addition
sell your information to other people
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your ISP can't see the sites
that you visit with 100 data encryption
you can allow expressvpn to run
seamlessly in the background with a
single tap of the button and their
software is one of the best that money
can buy with compatibility across
virtually every single device whether
it's your phone or your computer
expressvpn keeps all of your information
100 encrypted with the most powerful
encryption available protect your online
activity today with the VPN rated number
one by Business Insider visit the tow
exclusive link
expressvpn.com theories of everything
and you can get an extra three months
off for free off of the one-year package
that's
expresvpn.com theories of everything
expressvpn.com theories of everything
most of us share in the problem of being
so digitally active that we over consume
or over produce content which in turn
leads to an overwhelming amount of
monthly monetary subscription this
Channel's theme is exploration at least
one of the main themes and it's
difficult to paragonate when we're
handling the more routine and monotonous
items this is exactly why we're
partnering with today's sponsor rocket
money formerly known as true bill rocket
money automates the process of financial
saving and tackles the various
subscriptions that inevitably pile up
for all of us like Netflix phone bills
patreon subscriptions that aren't toe
Etc rocket money displays all of your
subscriptions tells you where you're
losing money and how to cancel them with
a single click of a button most of us
think that we spend approximately eighty
dollars a month on subscriptions but it
turns out that the average figure is in
excess of two hundred dollars get rid of
useless subscriptions with rocket money
now go to rocketmoney.com everything
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's rocketmoney.com everything
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now at rockmoney.com everything
I've almost never had a problem with
superposition because I see the math as
a description and then it's only an
issue if you try and make some
correspondence between a map and say
what the heck is going on so some people
would say yeah but it's not as simple as
if you have two goals so two plus two
goats equals four goats that I
understand however even there
two plus two equals four but two plus
two also equals five plus minus one
just as easily and so you can say well
what the heck is five goats and then a
minus one goat does it live in a
superposition of five and a minus one so
unless you have a problem with even
ordinary addition then to me I don't
have a problem with superposition I just
see it as okay this is a description so
what do you think about that what do you
make of that I think it's a great
example
um and it and and it conveniently gets
to the point that I was rounding on
anyway uh which is that we have
and intuition about mathematics we have
our own inbuilt math engine in our
brains
um and it it's you know we know that
that our intuitions about math do not
Encompass all math for example we don't
have an intuition about imaginary
numbers
but imagery numbers are perfectly
serviceable mathematical tools and in in
you know in a sense there
you're real in that they're important
for understanding quantum mechanics but
the uh foreign
the worlds that we describe the the
worlds that you know out the our
subjective World which is a model and
our scientific models
um uh
so heavily influenced by what we
intuitively think is possible but we
don't we shouldn't necessarily trust
what we think is possible based on
you know the the the math and physics
engine that Evolution gave us
um and so this is one
uh interdisciplinary area we need to
maybe talk to neuroscientists and you
know people who are uh to cognitive
scientists and and and and even people
who are working in AI to understand what
some of the biases might be in how
a neural network like our own constructs
its reality so that's what you meant
when you said there is physics to
understand fundamental reality but if we
also want to understand what do we mean
when we say fundamental reality we can
use tools of Neuroscience to understand
our own biases well that's so that
aspect of understanding ourselves is
important what are our biases but also
if we want to approach
things like the the measurement problem
I think you know maybe
understanding how we construct our
subjective reality won't get us there
maybe it'll be helpful but
there are I I feel like there are
um
areas in for example
well
statistics probability Theory I mean you
know these things physicists are pretty
quick to to draw on for example various
Bayesian interpretations of quantum
mechanics but I also think that we can
draw on
um
what you might broadly call systems
theory so how complex systems emerge
um to understand
the different hierarchies of complexity
okay
um I mean this is there are so many
rabbit holes that I'm avoiding leaping
right down I'm happy to go down them uh
one by one but sure but they're deep
do you find that you're having a
terrible amount of fun when you're
delving into the more
metaphysical side of physics and
interpretations so this film in
particular than you are with your own
research
uh
it's funny yeah so you know I
pursued astrophysics because it it
honestly just seemed like the most fun
asking big questions about really big
things but but over time I've become
more and more interested in the
fundamental and and making space time
has been a big part of that also
um and so I I have no regrets the the
universe is awesome
um and it's it's really fun to solve big
problems about the universe and also the
the skills I picked up doing that sort
of work I I'm able to bring to bear on
some of these other questions that said
you know I'm not
a Quantum theorist I'm not even what you
know most people would call a
theoretical physicist uh which means
there are there are some skills that
I'm going to have to work harder on uh
and so this movie is about
you know in a way it's a personal
Journey
um
in that I I really want to take stock of
the field
um and and the fields uh and to sort of
get a sense of where Humanity stands in
this question and what the paths forward
could be
um
and yeah so there's that personal level
but I also feel like it
you know it's it's a contribution I
think at some level
um it's you know we're by no means the
only people talking about this stuff but
I think there's
a rising Collective interest in this big
picture
um asking questions like you know
what are we doing anyway what what what
what is the goal of
Being Human and asking questions about
the world and
um
and
you know I think I think anything we can
do to sort of bring that Collective
curiosity together is is useful
especially these days
help me understand how one goes from
physics or even science which is to be a
description again how does one go from
that description to an ought
well I think I mean the the easy answer
is just
that whenever you grant perspective you
grant power
um you know it's the same reason we do
science communication on YouTube
um and
uh
you know I feel like it's no secret that
we are a deeply factionalized species
right now
fractionalized meaning yeah yeah
um
and and you know we've we've we've
buried our heads so deeply you know
we're sort of all we're all playing our
own little mini games you know where
where we're overwhelmed you know by by
the buzz of all media by
just the stuff going around the world
right now and so we we like to organize
the world into these simplified little
systems of elements and simple rules and
we sort of organized these mini-games of
life and then you know we try to win
them like whether we're winning games of
political Dynamics at work or you know
trying to just stay solvent and collect
enough retirement or you know the the
game of empowering your chosening group
so we we
um we diminish the world so that so that
we can handle it
um
and
I guess
the thing that science can do is that it
can show us
um it can show us
bigger Landscapes right we we are only
able so if you can imagine the infinite
landscape of you know possible ways to
live your life possible things you can
do ways to be uh we we tend to
um to blinker up and Define these
um these manageable sub Landscapes and
we you know navigate those little spaces
um but of course we inevitably come to
believe that our chosen little sliver
is the world as it really is
okay we we
mistake the sub game for the game and
our compactification of reality
in our minds becomes reality and
um and I am as guilty as most in that
but really I'd say any type of education
broadens perspective and shows us
grander games
um and that there are enormous
Landscapes of possibility you know
outside whatever erupt we happen to be
in
and so uh so
exposing people to new information
um is is usually always good okay there
are exceptions but science I find
particularly important and Powerful
because it's
in a way it's General so it's not
science isn't about the subject matter
it's about the methodologies okay the
methodology is if you like of Truth
finding
um and those methods can be applied at
least at some level to any question or
any field uh in ways that improve our
ability to explore the Landscapes of you
know that aspect of reality
um and so
uh
so I mean granting people the access to
some of the
just the things we've learned in the in
science that are incredibly powerful the
methodology is the ways of thinking even
just the habits of thought are
um just super powerful tools for
improving how people even live their
lives because these these ideas become
embedded
it becomes subliminal
um
and but I guess I maybe the way I think
about science is that it's uh like a
formalization of how our brains work
naturally
um if you think of our minds as tools
for navigating the world and and that's
the physical world the social world and
you know worlds of arbitrary abstraction
um and so so cognition which is the
process of asking questions seeking
evidence formulating models and
hypotheses and making choices
um which sounds more like science and
you know in our brains that's all
happening constantly and mostly
subconsciously
um
and
and also I guess an important thing is
that we don't just do this individually
so we
aging this sort of collective cognition
you know through discussion with each
other in an explicit way but also you
could argue that we are cogitating as a
society through ART and religion and
politics and
um you know so we can think about
culture I guess is this Collective
cognition
um and
even a
you know I like to think of culture as a
search algorithm for for truth okay so
if part of culture is a world model okay
and every culture has its consensus
reality then uh then
you know that that little kind of local
minimum in the possibility space of what
the world is and how to live
is something that that culture found
and so you know cultural Evolution I
guess sort of navigates the landscape of
possible ways to
think about the world and about
ourselves
um and and so
if science then
in some ways systematizes cognition and
can make us better at it individually or
collectively
then we get better at mapping the
landscape
um here's the fact that occurs to me if
science
is the epitome of making systematic what
is our cognition and what we're trying
to do or what you're up to with this
documentary is not only investigating
reality but trying to avoid some of our
own cognitive biases but I imagine if
science is modeling the way that our
brains work but our brains have a bias
then how does one scientifically not
have this bias built in it's super hard
and science is no guarantee against this
but I guess the the the
one to me one of the most incredible
things about the Scientific Revolution
is that
it gave us at least the potential for
meta awareness
um of
of the fact that there even is a
possibility landscape
you know versus a singular ground truth
um and the potential for the awareness
that there's a distinction between
reality versus a model of reality
philosophy also okay so so I think you
know uh I'm maybe
mixing together the the the
um
breakthroughs of of Enlightenment and
um
and
and you know so so these
fields of of rational thought
um allow us to at least in principle
know about that biases are possible this
might be inaccurate
um so you you know I I talk about
culture as a search algorithm for truth
um so I feel like science allows us to
upgrade that search algorithm so that
we're less likely to get stuck in a
local minimum but because we introduce
exploration into like with the the
explicit ability to explore to our
little a little
uh search algorithm
um
robot whatever it is a little Valley
crawler and uh and it also allows us to
explicitly incorporate uncertainties
into whatever the loss function of that
search algorithm
um so it's like a a meta expansion of
our ability to uh to explore possibility
space
so okay another thought that occurs to
me is this is not a thought that
this is not a Viewpoint that I have
necessarily but it's one that I'm sure
that someone or some people who watched
me have thought okay so we have a
cultural model of reality every culture
has this when we have science we have
something that we believe is a cultural
so it's non-cultural it's objective
however they would say yeah but that's a
eurocentric way of thinking because
we're though of course we're going to
say our culture is the one that has the
objective method so what would your
response be to that
I I I I I
really value this
um being brought to
attention because it's true that
uh that you know when we talk about
science it's not one thing
okay so there sort of is a eurocentric
culture that comes under the label of
science but that's not all that's not
all that science is
um
and
so science is also a
revolution in our ability to to cogitate
um on on many levels
um and that
is bundled with other
cultural factors uh in in some ways for
instance but but it also but it also
has its independent existence and the
value of the kind of the raw upgrade
that science gave us is that
in in principle and I've been careful to
say in principle in principle it allows
us the type of meta awareness that can
lead us to those sorts of biases
and
you know I I don't want to say that
uh the the Western Scientific Method is
how brains work it's absolutely not as
simple as that but there are there are
correlations that are powerful and that
I I think are
um
you know transcultural
and and that uh their uh wisdom
Traditions that talk about these things
in very different ways
um that right you should spend more time
trying to translate between yeah that's
my response as well well firstly one is
to say that science is not all in the
sense that well that's not only my point
of view Hillary Putnam said something
similar and same with Feynman he had
this famous quotation about logic is not
all that one needs hearts
and secondly that to call science
eurocentric is to not recognize the
contributions from many other cultures
yeah yeah I mean I I was echoing uh your
language a little bit there
um
you know the fact is that
you know a bunch of
old white European men dominated science
for quite some time and there's still
you know that that influence in some of
the
institutions of science
Henson shaving is a family-owned
Aerospace parts manufacturer that's made
parts for the International Space
Station and the Mars rover and now
they're bringing that Precision
Engineering to your shaving experience
so here's a personal story I gave the
razor to Sam who's working behind the
scenes here at the toe podcast I didn't
tell him who it was from I just said you
need a razor he said sure then I asked
him hey how was that razor the next
couple days later he's like Kurt that is
the best razor I have ever used and then
I said by the way that's a sponsor
Henson then he said that is fantastic
and he looked it up and they're an
aerospace engineering company so that's
in a Side Story that's a true story it's
packaged extremely carefully the handle
looks beautiful the assembly takes 10
seconds and the blade is as precise as
I've ever seen in a commercial razor by
using Aerospace grade CNC machines
Henson makes metal razors that extend
less than the thickness of a human hair
that means it's a secure and stable
Blade with no vibrations so the Razer
has built-in channels and it evacuates
hair and cream which makes clogging
virtually impossible you blow it out and
it's cleared that's what she said Henson
shaving wants to produce the best razors
not the best razor business so that
means no plastics no subscriptions no
proprietary blades and no planned
obsolescence and it's extremely
affordable The Henson Razer works with
the standard dual Edge blades that give
you that old-school shave with the
benefits of this new school Tech visit
hensonshaving.com everything if you use
that code you'll get two years worth of
blades for free just make sure to add
them to your cart that's 100 free blades
when you head to
h-e-n-s-o-n-s-h-a-v-i-n-g.com slash
everything and use the code everything
curious if you think a Theory of
Everything exists firstly secondly if we
could know it so that presumes that
there exists one
yeah well
so uh so I mean it depends what you mean
by a theory of everything I guess
um
you know
is there a single equation that drives
all of reality
and that knowing the equation would be
enough to
to make a new universe if you could
implement it
um
I
I yeah I really don't know the answer
it's possible
um
I
I am less and less inclined to get
behind the idea that there is a
single most fundamental
description that can be wrapped up in a
way that a human brain can comprehend
uh you know I think it
you know I was talking about the idea
that that we necessarily
uh only see a subset of reality and only
model set of reality okay now in in
the world that we walk through that we
inhabit our own uh subjective experience
and the
um
the the network of relationships that we
think govern the world so it's both you
know in our in our own mental
constructions of the world but also
in each separate academic field these
are these are slices
and we see that that these regularities
emerge from whatever's really there
and in in very particular ways we can
capture those regularities and turn them
into
an academic field or whatever
um
and so what physics has said is that all
right this is what we've been doing for
all of the history of you know
human inquiry is trying to find these
different ways to slice reality into
into networks of relationships
we think
that all of it emerges from a single
most fundamental uh rule essentially
and that might be true but I don't think
it's clear that it's true
I think
you know that might be one of the biases
our we've trained ourselves to believe
that that might be the case but you know
there's even
some emerging
ideas that really put to question the
notion of what
fundamental really means all right Steph
so
you know the
the
reductionist philosophy that we can you
know first we physically seek smaller
and smaller elements of reality than
seek
uh deeper levels of causation uh
until we find the bottom
um you know we should be ultimately the
most simple ideally
um
so
there are there are cases where it's not
true that the most simplest description
of reality is the most fundamental okay
so if you want to model say fluid flow
please use Bernoulli's equation rather
than Quantum field Theory even though in
principle you could use the latter the
latter is in principle more fundamental
um so you know these regularities arise
and and prove simpler than their
substrates the rules governing their
substrates if you wanted to do a
particular calculation in them
um
so so as you go up in in size scale or
in other other scales also complexity
scale you see things simplify and then
unsimplify
um and but but in in a way that means
that these what we would call these
layers of say emergent complexity are
not in in any way predictable from the
lower layers
um so Stephen Wolfram talks about the
idea of computational irreducibility
okay there there are things about the
universe that you can't predict without
literally running the universe and that
includes some of the the
incredibly beautiful and regular
patterns that emerge that um you know
for example fluid flow or life uh that
that you could never predict by looking
at a quark
so
so that's
the first point that
um
that the I guess what what was this
you might call this Newtonian Paradigm
where you know once you know how all the
little billiard balls are moving around
you can predict the universe is
only sort of true but in a meaningful
way it's not true
um
so
you know there are there are examples
like
um all right so let's let's dig down to
something closer to the fundamental
let's get into physics
um
highly speculative physics so like take
the the ads CFT correspondence right so
the holographic principle
so um so this is the idea that well let
let me give you the sort of popular
media View and the idea is that the that
our universe could be a hologram
uh that's projected inwards from
something happening on the the 2D
surface of the boundary
um and and therefore our universe is an
illusion and it's that service out there
that's real
um
and it's more complicated than that uh
obviously the the number of dimensions
and and the curvature of the Interior
but yeah but anyway the idea the idea
sure I presented usually presented is
that
that that we are a hologram and
whatever's real is out there
um that's that's absolutely not what ads
CFT is saying what it's saying is that
in what we call the bulk which is the
volume which is which would in this case
would be our universe we it's explained
by a gravitational Theory okay general
relativity and the surface is explained
by a field Theory a conformal field
Theory and it's not that
one causes the other
the um what adcft is saying is that they
are dual to each other so they are
called a duality they're equivalent
descriptions of exactly the same thing
and neither is more fundamental than the
other that to me is part of the problem
of the common purveyors of science
trying to mystify the public by saying
that the universe is unreal and it's
holographic well you just said there's a
duality what makes you think that the
boundary is more fundamental than the
bulk space you can't say that one is
more than the other if there's a duel
yeah exactly exactly right and
um
and and sometimes one does look more
real for example it's I mean ads safety
is a hugely useful Paradigm even if it
may not apply directly to our universe
because it's much easier to do
computations in one of these
representations than the other in some
cases and in other cases the other
representation is the one that's
tractable okay so in
uh the um
the
strong interaction limit
of one where you can't do
calculations you can't use for example
perturbation Theory to do calculations
like like inside a black hole uh in on
the on the other side in this case if
you have a black hole in the in the bulk
in our universe then its representation
on its surface
is
um weekly interacting structure that you
can do computations with okay and so uh
so neither is more fundamental just
sometimes one is useful and sometimes
the other is useful
uh and this isn't this isn't a fringe
example I mean it's a it's just a cool
example that these dualities
um which is not the sense of Duality or
dualism in philosophy at all it it means
that that two
seemingly different
descriptions uh like wildly even
contradictably different descriptions
represent the same thing uh two
different stories describe the same
thing so so string theory is Rife with
Duality is like at the limit of the
energy scales we see Elementary strings
and emergent strings sort of morph into
each other but also in you know more
accepted physics like in quantum
mechanics the idea of complementarity is
a duality
um so you know usually encapsulated or
summarized in uh the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle but the idea that
we can represent
all of matter as either a linear
combination of
uh
Quantum fields in position space or
their vibrational modes in position
space okay and that's a representation
of the universe or equally equivalently
we can do the same thing in momentum
space and
they're they're
very different stories about what the
world looks like but they're equivalent
and not and no one would argue that one
is more fundamental than the other
um while there are some people who on
the more again of a more esoteric end
who like to emphasize that it's all
vibrations and it's all waves yeah you
can Fourier transform so you can make it
discrete again
yeah exactly you know and then and then
you know we let's not even get started
on like the S Matrix or the
amplitudehedron which uh which are ways
to describe the interactions between
particles which don't even require space
and time and uh and waves and and
fall out in which you can
summarize pages and pages of calculation
with a few lines of calculation which
implies that these things should be more
fundamental but I don't think that's
clear I think that their their stories
about what's happening that have
incredible mathematical utility what
they are is a regularity
that we've discovered
uh you sound like Bernardo Castro have
you watched a bunch of his talks or his
podcasts I've seen I think I watched
your interview with Bernardo actually
um I think I agree with some of what he
says and I disagree with some other what
are the agreements that you think are
seen as controversial
so I I like his characterization of
um
Minds as
dissociative boundaries or or
agents in dissociative boundaries so you
know my understanding is that Bernardo
uh
rates Consciousness as the most
fundamental
um and so you know you talk about
the universe is this is this thing made
of Consciousness and then Consciousness
arises in the universe and and it and so
the idea of dissociative boundaries is
that like you you could if you had your
own internal dissociative boundaries you
could maybe have something like a split
personality or you know you wouldn't
remember that you'd done and you and and
things like that and so the idea that
it's a it's a nice
characterization
um
what I don't buy is that Baseline
statement that the universe that the
fundamental element of the universe is
consciousness I don't I don't see why
it's needed and I don't think there's a
good justification
um
yeah we could go further
you want to go further as to your
disagreements or your agreements or
something else
okay well just in the context of of what
we're discussing
um
so I think you know we're talking about
these dual descriptions of the world uh
so
um
you know I would say that
our minds are a
like a dynamical causal system okay so
something describable with a set of
Dynamics sure dynamics of you know
thoughts basically okay that that that
cause and influence each other and you
could and and you know the the field of
psychology
you could imagine as
uh an extremely early version of some
field where you came up with the the
internal dynamics of the mind okay but
but still
um
so so if you describe the mind as this
dynamical system
where there's
like genuine causal power
in within that system defined within
that system
um then uh
then
the The Duel to that would be a
you know our brains where you have this
dynamics of neurons and action
potentials
okay and so
um so I so you know my my
uh feeling on the matter is that
that well I can't believe I'm saying
what I think Consciousness is but I'm
horribly unqualified but but I but who's
qualified yeah right anyone with it so
let's go uh so uh so so either feeling
that yeah and and plenty of people have
said this before that that uh
Consciousness is what a type of
information flow feels like uh you know
more particularly I think it's what a uh
a type of data structure feels like when
it tells itself a story about itself
yeah do you see a circularity there
because we're defining Consciousness in
terms of so-and-so itself feels like and
then the question is well what does it
feel right right so the hard problem
let's let's uh let's solve it you know I
I have someone by the way who's
premiering in two hours from now named
Terence Deacon look at who he believes
he's solved the heart problem several
people believe they've solved the heart
problem and usually it means that
they've that they have a completely
different ontology oh I mean I'm looking
forward to watching it I'm gonna you're
not Terence Deacon have you heard of him
uh name's familiar but no he's a
linguist well he's a neuroanthropologist
and he studied under Chomsky he says he
disagrees with Chomsky about everything
except politics he's extremely extremely
bright and has an extreme what I call a
Velton it's an all-encompassing world
view such that it's a framework through
which you interpret the world so it's
more than simply a world view it's this
philosophy that you have such that you
can pose virtually any question to
someone someone who has a belt on
showing and someone like say Sam Harris
or Jordan Peterson you can ask Jordan
Peterson a question about anything like
why do birds fly like that he would say
it's because the edible mother he has a
framework I mean that can be a useful
thing but don't you think in a way it is
being stuck in part of the landscape uh
maybe a very useful part of the
landscape but
um so right you mentioned it's extremely
useful yes so when you don't have one at
least like for myself it's a
destabilizing place to be you're in
constant you're tentative your
rudderless but you're also not kidding
yourself
well I don't I don't know
I I don't know because then that depends
on so does our model of reality create
reality so it doesn't mean that if you
have a model it just is so there's
something called phenomenology so my
thought is that
um
I think it's clear that at some level
information that is undergoing a certain
Dynamics
itself feels like something
um and
you know I I think it it is
maybe enough for that that data
structure to
inspect itself
keep a story of itself
uh you know as it as it computes its way
to its next state and its next state and
it next in its next state it it has it
has this self-monitoring capability uh
and and ends up
telling itself that it's conscious okay
because it it inspects its own
inspection of itself uh add input item
um and so so
if
um
you know if information can be conscious
in some way and the universe is in at
least some sense informational it it can
be you know it can be thought to encode
information any particle encodes some
type of information even if it's only
about its own existence then uh you can
imagine this spectrum of Consciousness
uh
and so
the so bernardo's sort of
pan psychism
uh version of pan psychism
is
one in which he says that he says that
um
that the Consciousness is the most
fundamental element not the material
um I think you can be a pan psychist and
and not say that I think
we you know back to our discussion of
dualities these you can have two
completely different stories about the
world
um and completely different mathematical
Frameworks for describing its Dynamics
but they are ultimately describing the
same thing
and I think that's the case with
Consciousness I think
um
I think you can
take for example a conscious human mind
uh which we we can't argue has it has
Consciousness and you start taking
things away you scale down its ability
to tell stories about itself to
self-inspect okay you can for example
go on a Meditation Retreat and learn to
be be purely in the moment and and
only aware and and you can learn to
suppress all of the chatter all of the
internal dialogue you can suppress all
cognition uh you know essential periods
to a point where you are only perceiving
okay so you you still have a qualia
but you're not telling yourself a story
about that about that you're just you're
essentially just
being the data structure that your brain
has assembled about the outside world
without
without analyzing it okay so you know
that this is clearly it's clear that our
subjective worlds are informational okay
that all of this detail needs coded and
so
so
is there anything special about that
information structure that's just the
output of your you know visual cortex
etc etc that that you know presents you
this this image of the visual world is
that data structure conscious uh or that
data structure plus your you know your
attention module which is
so so you can you can really pair things
down so that you only have the the
minimum amounts that that you know you
can you can possibly have and still be a
person
um and it seems that that is still
conscious
okay so what's what's the difference
then
to the data structure that represents
your the the
uh the subjective world that your brain
assembled and
a data structure that contains similar
information that's not in a person well
the difference is that
it's not constantly telling itself a
story about what it says and it has no
memory so if you if you I mean imagine
for example that the entire universe was
conscious and was aware of itself you
know it told oh that was a star that
exploded I just made a Galaxy
but then you take away that story and it
just is the data structure of all this
stuff
uh what will be the difference between
just being Mata
unconscious matter and you know this
completely memoryless
uh you know conscious thing and my
argument is that there's no difference
and the thing that has no memory or
capacity to self-inspect
isn't really conscious but that at least
gives you a way to have a spectrum of
Consciousness like as soon as something
starts to have both a model of the world
and can tell itself a story about its
model of the world then it can start
telling itself it's conscious and and by
the way it's not that's not an illusion
the the whole idea that Consciousness is
an illusion I think is is as as bad a
fallacy as saying that the you know the
holographic principle bulk is an
illusion and the boundary is not in that
case where the universe is conscious and
it's not conscious of anything you're
saying that it's as if there's two
states of Consciousness one that's about
something and then one that is just
conscious pure Consciousness and that's
something that you can access when
you're in meditation well I feel like
you know Consciousness I think we
I think it's a poorly defined concept
uh it's
you know it it really emerges when we
get to start telling ourselves that we
have it
and and
you know we could we we can observe our
our own Consciousness because we are we
literally are part of
the data structure
that this Consciousness is okay it's not
like we're
a separate you know homunculus observing
the the data structure that our brain
synthesize we are that data structure
okay we that that literally is what we
are and inside that data structure
there's a model of ourselves
okay which we can also inspect
um
and so I think
uh
Consciousness is just a it is in this
sense
an emergent phenomenon
but there's no
no very hard line I I think for when it
emerges you know I'm I started all the
saying I'm no expert and and then
gave you this super uh long treaties as
though
um I know anything but uh
this is the picture that fills the least
contradictory to me uh
so then in this view is there such a
thing as free will
in this view yes correct my
misunderstanding friend the way that I
understand it is that there are some
atoms moving around and occasionally
that is something we call information
processing that information processing
is much like there's a lamp right here
that is casting onto the wall that wall
is now the feeling of Consciousness that
is is the effect and something is
happening here now that wall doesn't
cause anything with this light the light
will move around right now it's
stationary but the light can change
colors it can get brighter it can get
smashed on the ground and that wall
would change but I wouldn't say that
that wall has any causal influence on
that
so that's what I mean when I say that it
sounds like there is no free will in
what has just been outlined so please
correct my misunderstanding okay so
let's try to talk about Free Will so so
first of all
um so Baja my partner she's a science
journalist and who's written a lot about
these topics uh I encourage you to check
out her article in the Atlantic which uh
to do thanks thanks nonsense on the
topic um but but she she always
reminds me to think about these things
in the context of their historical
development so so pre-enlightenment
there was this idea that Free Will and
meaning and mind were
um inextricably attached to Notions like
God and the immortal soul
okay so when when those ideas started to
be questioned
was the same time that the materialist
Paradigm arose so the Newtonian world
view of
you know
atoms is bouncing around in the void
perfectly predictable clock work so at
the same time that we discarded or
started to discard the spiritual
and in that Gap we inserted this sort of
very first and and and and perhaps naive
um mechanistic determinism
uh Notions like Free Will which were
conjoined with God and the Soul got
thrown out with the bath water and were
replaced by the idea that that these
things are Epi phenomena of over you
know called mechanistic Universe
um so uh
so that that's one crime what is is it's
a it's a a gripe with the what I think
is an over simplification of the
um approach to to thinking about
free will but but all other things
related to the mind also
um so so let me
explain why my view does and
uh suggest that Free Will is an illusion
um and so what does it mean it means
Free Will is means that you make your
your choices are your own they're not
forced On You by something else
uh
and and for any choice you make you
could have chosen otherwise
and you know the standard argument is
that
that your choices are not yours because
they're determined by the particles that
you're made of okay you couldn't have
done it before is
so this is this this is the the argument
that you hear uh I won't mention any
names
um because
you know you so you couldn't have chosen
otherwise because the whatever the exact
position and velocity of all of your
subatomic particles uh set and how to
evolve according to the laws of physics
or that
you know if that
you know if those particles have some
fundamental Randomness then the
randomness is still not free will
okay so that's the this argument
um and first of all let me say that that
you know that picture of physics is you
know it's right in a sense okay so I I
believe that that
subatomic particles evolve according to
The Showdown equation
Etc uh and the subatomic particles have
no idea that they're in a brain or that
they're part of a choice or they
represent a data structure that's part
of that that data structure feels uh as
part of a choice
um
but the problem with this reductionist
argument is that it's
it's messing up its definitions and in
particular it's definitions of causality
so if we think about
um
the world is having these kind of layers
of complexity
okay you have
physics driving the atoms and chemistry
driving the molecules in biology driving
the cells then you could you could say
something like so if you want to talk
about
causality here in terms of the
hierarchies of of emergence then you
could say that that quarks and electrons
cause atoms atoms cause molecules core
cells cells cause apples and brains and
brains cause Minds right
um but this is a type of causation and
it's it's like this cross hierarchical
causation
but I would argue that there's a real
fundamental difference between that type
of causation to what you might call an
an intra-hierarchical causation that
defines the Dynamics within a given
layout can you give me an example all
right so
you can say that you know there's this
causal power whereby a cell is or say a
neuron is caused by the molecules that
it's formed of
um it is an Epi phenomenon of those
molecules which in turn are Epi
phenomena of their atoms Etc but it's
also entirely meaningful to say that
an action potential in a neuron
causes a downstream neuron to fire
right so that's that's a reasonable
statement okay and you're on Fires one
that's attached to fires and you can you
can and and it and it makes total sense
and and in a real sense it's true to say
that the first neuron caused the firing
of the second
um it's
less useful to say that like
the wiggle of a Quantum string
on the Planck scale caused a downstream
neuron to fire even if the
even if the quantum string is the let's
call it the hierarchical cause of one of
the electrons in the first action
potential that's like a a roundabout and
relatively inane approach to talking
about causation so there's this this
kind of bottom-up causation in which
different levels in in
the scale of uh you know uh
physical scale or complexity scale are
generated by the the lower layers but
there's a different type of causation
within the layer okay so
um and and and within each of these
hierarchical layers you have
a a dynamics that is in a sense
independent of
the the layer below that generated it
okay so you can
um you know I mentioned Bernoulli's
equation and fluid flow so you you have
this whole field of hydrodynamics which
is beautiful and in a sense it's
causally closed Like You can predict
anything about the behavior of fluids
using these rules and
it it does matter what the properties of
the the particles in that layer are and
those properties are the properties of
those particles are generated by the
layer below but once you know the
properties of those particles you don't
care about the the the detailed physics
of the the level below you you are you
are in that layer and the rules of that
layer are in a sense closed and
independent Okay so
so brains
have a dynamics of neural activity okay
it's a physical system they behave
like some type of neural network we can
we can even simulate it okay current
neural networks miss an awful lot but in
principle we'd be able to
run the the Dynamics of the brain with a
different substrate we can run them we
could run we one day probably will be
able to run these in silico and it and
that dynamical system the system of of
neural activity will be independent of
the substrate once we figure out what
that Dynamics is man Matt you oh the I
don't know if you realize we've seen
such controversial statements at at
saying in principle so for instance you
see in principle we could simulate the
brain substrate Independence who knows I
mean well that's like a huge offer well
I'm I'm gonna understand I'm going to
crap all over the expression in
principle I think because
um so yeah who cares we're just talking
at people who are listening just realize
that none of us have the correct words
and in order for us to just in order for
us to convey anything that's non-trivial
we're going to have to flummox a
flounder okay well I'm happy I'm happy
to put myself out there I think we will
be able to simulate the brain but it
might be a really long time away because
there's so much
and and the point is that once we once
we figure out those Dynamics it'll be
independent of the substrate silicon or
meat in the case all right so
maybe we can agree that that the
Dynamics within a layer are their own
thing they're they're in a it and and
the idea of cause within one of those
layers like
is different to the cause that generates
one layer from the layer below it okay
uh I see what you're saying okay okay so
you have you have you have this
dynamics of cause and effect
in you know in biology or in an
ecological system okay it's true that
reintroducing wolves to the Yellowstone
National Park
caused
the deer population to be come under
control okay that's that's a totally
meaningful statement and it would serve
to try to do the same thing with quarks
okay yes yes like Studios right so so
you have these these dynamical systems
where where and and the cause in that
sense is it is like we should have a
different word for it but
um so we're mixing our definitions of
the interest system versus the
inter-system causation
so we're still not we're still not at
Free Will yet so
um our conscious experience
may be emergent from the actions of our
neurons it probably is in some sense
um
but
in another sense it is dual to our the
actions of our neurons Okay so
the the
L
neurons have a Dynamics which you know
you can at some level explain their
behavior
but the uh
that and they generate this pattern of
information that's you know it tells a
story about itself Etc and and so
um in a way
our minds or or you know the description
of our minds is just another way of
casting
that it's that that is a you know it's
essentially a duality it is a dual to
that system but in a way you could argue
that it's more fundamental right so
if in the broader sense our minds are
the result of a computation then then
our minds are also a dynamical system
independent of the substrate
um so a set of elements in this case
thoughts linked by a set of rules uh and
you know and and thoughts a symbolic
representations and so you can come up
with a a language that that
that manipulates these symbolic
representations and tells stories with
them okay that's you know in
uh sense kind of what what a mind is
um and a bunch of other stuff okay so in
a Sense Psychology is the science of
understanding the Dynamics of that
system and it's to some extent mappable
maybe never completely
um but it you know you but you you could
write down the Dynamics of the mind
without referencing neurons
okay just as you could write down the
Dynamics of the neurons without
referencing electrons but and the reason
I said that that in a sense the the
uh
the way of looking at neurodynamics
which is the
the the The
Duel of it which is the subjective
experience is more predictively powerful
than the neurodynamics themselves in in
you know some way of looking at it
that's more fundamental
um there are things you can predict
about what a brain will do and and what
what an organism how an organism will
behave that you could only get by
looking at the uh the the thought
Dynamics like the mental Dynamics and
you could never get by trying to look at
a few neurons and and guess what they're
going to do okay so is this not a
difference between what we can do and
what is
I don't think so
um
so
all right so
so we so first of all mate let's uh
you know
put a pin in the idea that the mind is
this
its own dynamical system potentially
independent a bit substrate uh
and
and understanding the Dynamics of the
mind is better than understanding the
Dynamics of neurons for for many many
things but
does it mean does that mean uh that yeah
like you said it is the mind
is this just our impression that you
know it's we can't do this we we can't
for example
predict someone else's detailed Behavior
you know uh their
inclination to
fall in love with you know particular
Types of People based on looking at
their looking at their neurons or
looking at their quarks okay but but
okay so now we get to this idea of in
principle yeah okay is it
that's the title of the podcast
uh is it even
in principle possible to do so
um and I would argue they are also no
um it's in principle possible to predict
some human behavior by
trying to model the physical aspects of
the brain
but I don't think it's possible to uh
so so here things get a little bit messy
so so you could predict someone's
Behavior just by knowing them well
does that mean they have no free will
that they couldn't potentially do
otherwise
uh
you could
predict someone's
inclination to certain types of behavior
by knowing you know about any
neuropathologies that they might have
okay so so for sure we aren't
uh
you know the epitome is a free will we
we often fail to exercise free will or
we are predictable
but the idea that
Free Will is an illusion because brains
are mechanistic I think is a little
fallacious and
and the reason is that so
so if a brain
because of that dual notion
well not not even I think we can go to
to physical here like there are physical
ish reasons here so so the brain
the idea is that that your actions are
predetermined and predictable because
the they're entirely determined by the
configuration of physical
matter and and so on
um
but but then you know I want to ask
to whom is the brain predictable and
predetermined okay to what observer in
what reference frame
uh so if you have any sufficiently
complex system like the brain uh you the
Dynamics
are coupled across multiple physical
scales like so so
um
so for example uh a an important part of
the
decision mechanism in the brain is the
so-called bryshark potential which is
just the the way the brain
uh it it's uh
basically the the correlated noise and
brain signal that the that the brain
actually uses to as a sort of a
tiebreaker in decision making
um and it and it partially drives the
Dynamics in ways that we don't very well
understand that all because it's super
new that we figured out but can you
repeat the name of the potential
it's the bryshark potential it's also
called the Readiness potential okay yeah
uh and you you want to look at
um
Aaron Sugar's work uh and uh and
actually
Baja wrote an article on this I'm just
mentioning that because I'm super
familiar with it now but it's just one
example of uh how uh that you have
Dynamics influence in complex and even
pseudo chaotic systems you have these
Dynamics linked across you know multiple
scales of these hierarchies and
and in that case
it it becomes
essentially impossible to predict
Behavior based on the uh you know the
smallest piece that like the smallest
elements of the substrate whatever the
the the atoms
um and
okay so you have this you know system
that that is in
you're partially chaotic uh and it's
well known that these things can't be
predicted by
without without
infinite computation okay I think I
think this is a manifestation of this
computational irreducibility also
um Okay so
Okay so
so my question is
what Observer or what reference frame
could predict your actions perfectly by
knowing
the exact state of all the quantum
fields in your brain
um so so you could you could imagine you
know some
uh super Advanced alien that could
somehow perfectly scan your brain and
get that and then run a simulation of
your brain at the same time but but even
that I think here like the very nature
of quantum mechanics makes that
challenging Okay so
so you literally need to track every bit
of quantum information in
the most complex systems to make a
perfect prediction okay so maybe you can
make some predictions but it's not even
practically impossible it's in it's
probably even in principle impossible
okay so you you have things like the no
cloning theorem which forbids you from
making a perfect copy of quantum
information
um which is what you would need to do to
make a perfect prediction so
so
so
I think in a meaningful way it's
in principle not possible for any
possible Observer to perfectly predict
your choice okay it is possible for
impossible observers like laplace's
demon who knows the exact position and
velocity of every particle in the
universe
uh so from the perspective of laplace's
demon you have no free will but
laplace's demon is a mythical entity
and
um and and like other mythical entities
I don't think we should rate something
an illusion because a mythical entity
could in principle predict your
um your behavior so there's this guy
named David walpart I don't know if you
know him but he's in Santa Barbara I
believe and he has the limits on
inference machines which says that even
lap class is demon in Newtonian
mechanics can't exist
I agree that laplace's demon cannot
exist I think even relativity forbids
laplace's demon because there's an
infant there's a there's a limit to how
quickly
it could anyway like this yeah yeah yeah
okay so you know so so you know long
story short I think Free Will is
real in a meaningful sense okay we're
like going down the definition of real
is like a whole other podcast but free
was real in a meaningful sense because
choice is a fundamental dynamical
component
in a particular dynamical system whose
behavior is independent of its substrate
and whose behavior is not
fully predictable in the context of its
substrates by by
mapping its substrates
um you know you know
in a way that is possible for any entity
that that could exist uh
but if you choose to not believe in free
will then
at least you have that choice
yeah okay great well man there's so much
that we can talk about okay how about
instead of delving more deeply into I'll
just tell you the one thought I'll just
tell you one of the thoughts why is this
notion of to who imported for instance
we can say there is a computer here
when we consider that to be an objective
fact we don't say this computer is here
to who unless you are someone who
believes that the Observer creates the
reality
so let's disregard that interpretation
say there's an objective reality so why
is it that we're saying Free Will exists
to who why can't we just say Free Will
exists in the same way that this
computer exists
yeah I mean we live in a we live in a
relative Universe particles
have a relative existence you know uh uh
Hawking radiation
only exists
if you're a certain distance away from a
black hole unreal radiation only exists
if you're
uh accelerating uh so so there I mean
there is a sense in which
um the frame of reference is is is
critical
um and for like non-noisy
so there's something noisy about the the
radiation and the unra radiation so the
Hawking radiation and that one yeah well
I think I think so maybe I I do I don't
know but there's there is something
non-trivial about the relativity of
existence in terms of matter uh for sure
um and
so I mean this is this is something I
don't think we've properly wrapped our
heads around you know maybe it's as
confusing as the measurement problem the
idea that
the universe
can look Canon does look radically
different depending on your frame of
reference
um
and the only thing that is consistent
is the self-consistency of the universe
itself it like no matter
what changes you know based on your
frame of reference
how you choose to make measurements
for example in you know things like a a
bell test
these these things radically can
radically change what the unit what
Universe you see
the the one thing that never change
changes is that
the universe remains self-consistent for
all Observers
okay can you explain what that means and
it's that different than the statement
that the laws of physics are the same
um
so in the case of
well I mean the simple case of of
Relativity yeah like let's take the
simple case of the twin paradox where uh
so this is this for an experiment in
relativity where a pair of twins one
jumps in a spacecraft and Zips off at a
large fraction of the speed of light and
you know
hangs comes back several years later
from the perspective of between on at
home and
um the the twin at home has aged and the
twin who travel is much younger because
time ticked slower for the twin who was
traveling
um because of their relative speed
okay so from the point of view of the
the traveling twin they didn't think
that their clock was tickets
okay uh they you know they were looking
back home and they thought that at home
the Clock Was ticking fast and
um and from
but that no wait on
no I should know this stuff
um so the the the so so so this is a
this is a
this is a so-called power you should go
you should watch this PBS space time
yeah yeah
the the way it works is that that that
When You observe a clock that's
traveling at some speed that clock
appears to tick slow all right so so
fast moving objects the time slows down
so so both twins see each other's clock
as ticking slow all right because the
spaceship is moving fast but then for
the for the astronaut twin earth appears
to be moving backwards quickly because
you know
velocity speed is relative
there's no preferred inertial frame of
reference so if it races away that twins
clock seems to slow down and yet when
the twin gets back home after that long
trip
the the twin who stayed at her so it has
to end up being consistent which one
aged more than the other and the answer
is that there is an answer that there is
a self-consistent answer when they get
home both of them agree that the twin
who stayed home aged more
but how can that work if both of them
saw the same change in each other's
clock and
they both of the twins have an answer
for that
and their answers are different but they
lead to the same conclusion okay the
twins at home
sees
the traveling twins clock tick slower
and so that the traveling between ages
less okay and and gets home meanwhile
the one at home is waiting and and
getting older and his twin comes back
much younger okay because the less time
passed but for the traveling twin
they watch the the the the twin at home
uh and and they watch the the twin at
home's clock tick slower so in fact the
traveling twin feels themselves aging
Lassa aging faster
until the moment that they turn around
okay so in order to turn around and come
home they have to accelerate
and the other thing that Einstein's
relativity tells us is that if you are
deep in a gravitational field your clock
ticks slower
okay so the amount that that twin has to
accelerate in order to return home
causes their clock to slow down enough
that that from their perspective
between who is at home
not only caught up to them but aged a
lot more okay yeah they both have
different stories about why
um
why they both agree that the traveling
twin is younger than the the
stay-at-home twin
um and so
Kurt how did we get to this so this was
in service of a point
okay so firstly I was asking about what
does it mean to be self-consistent oh
yeah yeah so that so the universe will
always conspire to be self-consistent
and and and that
uh observers will
you know ultimately agree
um and
I have so many questions here that's
even the case that's even the kids with
particles like uh if you if you see
unreal radiation I don't know what the
solution to this one is
um
someone else doesn't see under radiation
but they see
yeah it's like if you if you accelerate
fast enough then you'll you'll be
incinerated by what what's the
equivalent of Hawking Recreation it's a
type of horizon radiation you'll be in
but
someone who is not accelerating
doesn't see your unrew particles
and yet does see you incinerated
so why does the the person who's not
accelerating CU incinerated I think the
answer is
you they see you being incinerated by
something else like the drag on the
quantum fields or something I
I I don't recall but but there was a
there's a neat answer to it like the
universe keeps conspiring to give us
these neat answers that everyone
ultimately is going to agree even if the
universe that they
think they live in looks wildly
different to the universe of the next
person the the consist the consistency
conspires to always be there
um and I think there's a mystery there
and I don't know what okay so Matt
a couple questions occurred to me so one
when we use the word self-consistent to
apply to the universe I mean why can't
we just remove the word itself and say
the universe is consistent so that's
number one and then number two what
would it look like if there was
inconsistency does it mean that there'd
be disagreement between us because there
already is disagreement and then if
we're saying it's no scientific
inconsistency well then science bites
Nature's intersubjective agreement which
means we've had disagreements we've
pushed on the side and so it's like
saying we agree because I've removed the
disagreements so why do we use the word
self-consistent secondly
we what the heck would it ever look like
to be inconsistent
right so by self-consistent I mean
internally consistent
um which means that I mean you you can
imagine consistency is in consistent
with someone's beliefs about what the
universe should be but that's not the
case
um and the universe when you know to for
carefully made measurements and and it
is always
but always obeys its own rules
but the the particular rule that it
seems to be obeying may be different for
one Observer or another but but all
observers will obey
we'll all see that the universe
obeys its rules its own rules
um
so in the example of the twin paradox
the
one twin observes the universe obeying
the rules of time dilation due to uh due
to uh special relativity and the other
observes surveying the rule of time
dilation due to you know acceleration by
the equivalence principle General
activity at least in one's way of
framing that Paradox um in in the case
of the unru radiation uh they everyone
everyone sees the accelerating person ex
incinerate okay and so it's not like one
person
sees them survive and the other person
sees them and then accelerate it okay so
which would lead to a paradox okay so
the universe never generates paradoxes
it
always you you will always find that
that it has
obeyed
its own you know it's its laws of nature
uh if it doesn't then it it's us who
haven't figured out the right laws of
nature but but the thing is to observers
me
see it doing that in different ways and
the the original example of this is is
good old electromagnetism where
um
you know a a moving electric charge
generates a magnetic field
um but we know that motion is relative
so if you're if you're moving with the
electric charge
you should see no magnetic field but
that magnetic field has an effect okay
if it causes other charged particles to
move
um and and so that it would be
inconsistent if one person saw a moving
charge particle generate a magnetic
field and the effect of that magnetic
field you know resulting in the motion
of yet more particles
and person traveling with the magnetic
field sees that sees no such thing that
would be an inconsistency and a paradox
in a sense
um because
there would be an irreconcilable
disagreement
um about their observations but there
are but the reality is that
um the person traveling with the charge
does see a force on the uh surrounding
particles but to them they they would
argue that the force was from the
electrostatic build which is the force
that that you know the the
right so so the so that's an example but
that but nonetheless the universe has
obeyed its own rules
it's just the different observers would
disagree on which rule which rules did
obeyed
um and and no Paradox is interesting so
that's what I mean by that
um what was the what would it look like
to be inconsistent and then also when I
when we say that the world is consistent
like I mentioned we do have
disagreements and there is such a thing
as someone seeing something that you did
not see and we generally consider those
to be mental illnesses but I'm sure
there exists other cases that are not so
extreme though I can't though none come
to mind and in which case would that be
in like science we'd say well
scientifically and so on like I
mentioned you just remove the qualities
that we dislike and we say they have no
qualities we dislike
yeah I mean ultimately to to test uh to
test consistency
the the result from both observers has
to come back to one Observer so so so
you one Observer needs to test the
consistency and
um that
consistency check would be that
ultimately all of the incoming
information agrees
um like
uh so in the twin paradox both of them
agree that the stay-at-home twin aged
and the asteroid twin
uh stayed Young
but
you know they they won't know that until
they talk to each other about it and and
then each of them independently
has
a self-consistent model of the world oh
my brother returned
and is younger to my vision
and also tells me that
they agree with that assessment okay so
so if your your brother came back and
told you that
wait no I
feel myself as being old and you look
young then that would be an
inconsistency okay so the data
that that's coming into your your head
has to
um has to line up
and it should line up and maybe this is
just an axiom of of science that that
um
that the universe is internally
consistent or self-consistent and I
think it you know it's reasonable to say
that it is one of the axions that we
just have to start with but it it is
stunning how
the the range of circumstances where it
demonstrates itself to be correct in
ways that you know the number of
paradoxes seeming paradoxes that have
Arisen and have not had a clear solution
but in fallibly a solution appears
okay speaking of consistency does
girdle's incompleteness theorem have
anything to say about physics or the POS
the existence of a toe yeah it sure
feels like it should doesn't it you know
um
How does it go again no
system of axions either no
self-consistent system of axions no
formal language
uh
and prove all of the truths
that it can represent yeah there always
exist at least one truth that's
unprovable from the set of axioms if
it's consistent and it's strong enough
to encode the the basic arithmetic that
we take for granted
yeah I I mean it
I I would say
maybe
um
so I mean the idea so let's assume that
there is a ground truth to reality that
there is a
a
baseline fact about reality that
um
explains
why there's something rather than
nothing why it behaves the way it does
etc etc
uh you know I mean so
in in any formal language that we can
come up with including math
there's no guarantee that
that
um that ground truth is
is provable because there are always
some that are not
um
but yeah I don't see it as a reason to
be too despondent
um
because if a uh
a truth is not provable in one formal
system then it may be in others
um
and
yeah yeah so I I'd say I'd say the the
the the risk more is that
um we
either that
singular ground truth doesn't exist okay
so it it may really be that that there's
this sort of
relativity of Frameworks and there's no
singular framework in which we can
Express the the sort of what people have
you know wanted to find this the idea of
this final theory that
that there's you know in a sense no
ultimate theoretical ground beneath our
feet
um
which is
to me
both
a bit terrifying it gives me vertigo to
think about it yeah yeah I just had some
of that as well but it's also cool man
because
then when you when you think about what
we are in such a universe you know where
it's like where the where where this
layer of emergent complexity that's
bootstrapped up from nothing
and you know it's it's now to us to
explore this uh this this crazy
phenomenon of reality and and try to
characterize it as best we can
with no
um
you know like the idea there's no ground
truth there's certainly no fundamental
meaning uh in that picture there's
there's only the meaning that we impose
on it
um that if you think about
humans as explorers you know we uh have
broken free from our bounds
um on on so many levels and and you know
for most of our history it was the it
was physical bounds you know we we
explored the world okay then we left the
world and and went to other worlds well
the moon
um but with our science we've explored
the physical Universe to its boundaries
but there's also there's other type of
exploration that that you don't think
about so we we kind of live in these
day-to-day subjective worlds which are
these like these mini games that I sort
of talked about the the idea we just try
to find the regularities that are
convenient enough and and those are
imposed on us by Evolution too like
where where we
believe in a world mate where there's
space and time and hierarchies of
objects and there are relationships
between these things forces Etc which is
just one
very selective way of casting reality
but uh but it's also a very natural and
it's the one that we were born into in
the same way we're born in a country but
we have broken free from that bound too
and we're capable of
like literally arbitrary abstraction and
exploring all of the ways to to frame
reality and and none of them are better
than any other in terms of more
fundamental so we're we're we are adrift
um but which is and and you mentioned
this earlier but it's a it's really a
terrifying thing
you know how how do you
choose a world view how do you anchor
yourself down and say right this is my
world view this is how I'm going to
interpret everything and and
choose my actions yeah I would say that
double down on
the power of this relativity on the
power that you have of having cut
yourself loose
from these you know these the bonds of
the framework that you were born into
your your you know your
uh
Surfer impossibility space
um to me that's actually
uh something you can
put an anchor in
um
explain that well you can put an anchor
in the fact that you are in the in
the the so
in your in I mean you can take pride in
your knowledge
in your ability to
you know have this meta awareness that
that
um a world view
is at some level an arbitrary choice
and and you can see that there are many
possible World Views and you you know so
I'm not saying that that I can do this
but it but I can see that it that this
could be an admirable
um
type of existence is to to see these
uh these different you know local Minima
in the landscape each one A different
belief system and and
world view and
idea about what reality is
um but but knowing the Landscapes there
and even at some level being free to
move
um is
um it's just it's just damn cool man I I
think it's an increase
foreign
it's a unique
um quality of human beings it's what
makes us
I think true General intelligences
although we have we have deep
constraints and we we have to
you know fight a lot of our inclinations
to to do one thing over another in many
cases we
uh we still have the capability to to
uh
to see all this stock to see all the to
see all of the different
Frameworks in which the universe can be
seen and to in some way explore them
to Define ourselves and
um
yeah I feel like just that that fact it
is
is its own meta worldview
is this one of the reasons you started
the film and by the way your film is
called inventing reality so imagine that
several of the themes we talked about
will be covered in the film exactly what
was the impetus behind the film
so the
so
Bahar and I were planning to make a show
together
um so she's a science journalist and
and you know I I'm
I'm an emerging
science Communicator
um and two million subscribers and is
emerging geez
well in terms of my skills maybe
um and so we were planning to make a
show it was going to be called the
reality show and it was going to be a
you know a riff on reality reality TV
but really oh interesting interesting
yeah it was going to be a fun way to
look at how people are exploring the
nature of reality and this was this was
like five years ago so when you say you
were working on a show you mean a show
like on TV or Netflix or we we you know
it was we were friends showing many
things it was maybe going to be a
YouTube show because that's what I knew
um
whatever stuck uh and then we got
distracted you know I got I got
um distracted by my research program
possible to
to do that and space-time which we can
talk about next time when we speak which
is the crisis in cosmology because
there's so much that I would love to
know about that
absolutely
um
and uh so so it's it's just that was
something that we have been talking
about for a long time and
and you know also talking about these
questions and and uh peeking into these
together but but also on the other side
with
um uh Andrew cornhaber and Eric Brown
who were the producers of space-time
we've been talking for a long time about
doing something big
um in terms of
reaching
um a bigger audience and uh you know
what we would want to say it would be
your audience
um and how we can
just do something
you know really cool with what what we
thought was this in this affordance we'd
we uncovered which is the appetite
for
um
good depth and you know some level of
authenticity
um so so these two
projects merged into this film inventing
reality
um and we
uh
we were very lucky to have a
um
well I guess a a fan of the show but now
a friend
um offered to match funds
um up to four hundred thousand dollars
actually so we wow great all right time
to
try to crowdfund this and and we you
know the reason we wanted to do that the
reason we didn't want to
um I mean it you know PBS is awesome but
this this kind of had to be something
independent
um
because we want we wanted absolute
absolute creative freedom
they're a great partner for space time
but we wanted this one it had to be
absolute creative freedom and we also
realized that uh that that the appetite
for this could actually let us fund it
um
uh so so that's what we're doing so
what's the website
so it's in we're we have a Indiegogo
crowdfunding Indiegogo if I was to
search inventing reality it would come
up sure hope so
let me do so right now
yeah okay I see it I see it I'm not I'm
going to be donating to this oh good
thank you
well I want to see this made
so
um we're gonna do our best we're one day
into the campaign by the time I guess
this video is out will be a little more
than that let me read some of this if
you don't mind because this is
interesting to the listeners our
space-time and particles even real hey
if you thought Donald Hoffman was
allowing your mind to be untrammeled in
a positive or negative sense then
he's uh he's adding particles to this
makes matte designing particles well
particles are definitely not real good I
could tell you that now I gotta I gotta
drive home and function so
is reductionism a dead end
can physics ever hope to find ground
truth interesting interesting
so it seems to me like
even in this conversation of there are
there may not be ground truths even that
statement alone maybe a ground truth of
sorts so it's a it's a such a tricky
statement to make that there are none
and that we can say that there are none
of a certain class so that's why I like
this yeah yeah there are physics ever
help to find crowd truth final terms
also and for people who are fans of the
toe podcast something I talk about
frequently is abijnasis which means how
do you combine basically science has
evolved it's not it's not the same that
it was 300 years ago so then the
question is what is it evolving to and
can other modes of knowing quote-unquote
knowing be integrated with science and
so I call that in a tongue-in-cheek
manner
abiginosis which is gnosis of the
western average
I forget the root word of the East but
it's not as if that that's the only two
maybe there's maybe there's four maybe
there's five different ways of
integrating knowledge anyway so if
you're interested in that can physics
ever hope to find the ground truth
that'd be interesting to you what is the
role of the of the observer in quantum
mechanics okay that's like a central
thing this is uh did you what did you do
man did you just copy all the did you go
to the toe description and create the
the ideal movie
no man we did we just have the same
Curiosities because
I know I'm just kidding around man
yeah yeah exactly these are the
questions I have a personal question for
you as you start to investigate this
further and further do you find that
you're questioning you've at first we're
thinking how do I unify quantum
mechanics or Quantum field Theory with
gravity it's like okay that's the most
fundamental question then you get to
ideas of what the heck does it mean to
cause what does it mean to be real
what does it mean to mean do you find
that that's the case for you it's
paralyzing but I guess you have to power
through of course yeah and I think it's
important
um I mean the key is once you do that
staying on track you know you can't
follow one line of reasoning and
and well you can follow unloaded
reasoning and be diverted at every
definition
um and
you know this is what makes Smart people
smart is they're able to construct these
These Chains of reasoning and
you know flag their potential
you know uncertainties biases
definitional uh uncertainties along the
way and then come back and build build
the the edifice of their understanding
but it's it's
it can be really paralyzing for sure
um what does mean even mean
I thought that one but now I will here's
something that I asked Noam Chomsky it's
a similar question that I asked you is
that in order to know what something
means do you have to know what it not
what it doesn't mean so in order for you
to understand what a cat is does that
mean you have to point out instances of
non-cats he said yes but then to me this
there's something defeating about that
and it's defeating in in a in the sense
that he says we don't have a definition
of meaning so how are we supposed to
know if something is meaningless without
presupposing that you know what meaning
is
uh I mean maybe yeah right I mean
meeting is about
a correlation between
two things and in particular between
some
you know informational representation
and the thing itself I suppose
um
in in a simple sense you know
this word means this animal and both of
them
have
some informational correlate in your
brain uh and so it's the pointers
between these interesting things right
um but but I I
am sure
that Noam Chomsky has thought all
through this in a lot of detail and
means something deeper when he says we
don't know what meaning means I think
that's I think it's the case that
nonchovsky's
whatever people think about him
politically
I think it's absolutely
sharp like a sharp as a thumbtack at 92.
sharper than most people are at their
Prime and he's 92 or 93. I was even
talking to Terence
like genius said no no question yeah so
just as an ending as an ending statement
there's the hard problem of meaning at
least this is what I call it there's
something called the symbol grounding
problem so you can look this up it's
sent it means how is it that when we say
the word pen we mean pen how is that
word ever how does that word point to a
pen what does the pointing mean
that's something that yeah I get much
attention my feeling is so ultimately it
has to be to something in your
you know in your brain or in your
conscious experience and it's really
hard to pin down because
you know what you have a single neuron
who's firing means you've thought of pen
that's that itself is not very
meaningful
um because the neuron is
you know
uh tentacally lipid layer uh structure
it doesn't mean pen so so the meaning
has to arise in a different way and I
think
the only way to me that makes sense is
that
the
the
representation of Penn in in your head
comes
has its entire existence in
the connection of all of the things that
you relate to penis and and
um
you know it's it's function its shape
and and all of these have have
representations elsewhere in your head
and and it's in the combination of these
that you get the notion of the pen but
then you ask for each of those other
things like okay you need you need to
connect Inc what about ink how does ink
does income know that itself is also
this connection of representation so
once you strip away
all of those uh representations the pen
vanishes there isn't even you know a
a single neuron left where
that that meant Penn now has no
qualities that there's nothing and so
um that's what that's what it feels like
um which is again uh
an ungrounding notion
um that that meaning only exists in the
relationship between
the properties that that
um you know
yeah so so that's uh my now that word
ungrounding did you you use that
purposefully because I called I mean
because I referenced the symbol
grounding problem or did you just use
that word
uh I didn't mean to copy you but no no
it's not copying me it's actually the
word that is appropriate and and but
it's there's also a technical meaning of
that word and the conversation with
Terence Deacon which is actually
premiering in about an hour or so talk
specifically about that it's difficult
to say what grounding is but he and does
it mean in that context grounding to
some kind of
your neurostructure or a neurocarily
as far as I understand
grounding is
something physical and so what's meant
by the word pen is ungrounded is that
there's nothing that you can see from
the symbols of the word pen that grounds
it to the word pen but it has something
to do with it being grounded in
something physical Matt
thank you thank you so much man listen
because it was an absolute pleasure and
based on who you've had on this podcast
and and the brilliant conversations
you've managed to get out of them also
which is no mean feat um it's an honor
so
an honors mine then like I but I've been
watching you for years I I watch you
guys I go to sleep that sounds creepy
I'll watch it before yeah and and so
it's and I've been doing that for years
and and I learned from you and several
met perhaps the majority of the audience
has plenty to credit to you in terms of
their knowledge so thank you
well I I was just communicating it so
glad I got some across the podcast is
now concluded thank you for watching if
you haven't subscribed or clicked on
that like button now would be a great
time to do so as each subscribe and like
helps YouTube push this content to more
people also I recently found out that
external links count plenty toward the
algorithm which means that when you
share on Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you